a surprising hostage situation A
visually stunning final course and one
Chef's Legacy literally going up in
smoke the ending of the menu continues
to Delight viewers for so many reasons
one of the biggest mysteries in the menu
is Chef slowik since it seems like he's
really going through a full-on breakdown
throughout the night he makes a creepy
early impression with a disturbing tale
of childhood trauma made all the more
chilling by Rey finds incredible
Performance Plus he's somehow been able
to convince his staff to follow him to
the end literally he's ready to end it
all and he's planning to take his guests
his staff and himself out in a ball of
fire so why is Chef slowik suddenly
ready to end everything the accomplished
Chef explains that after years of
cooking overly artsy food for unworthy
and disrespectful clients he's
completely lost his passion for cooking
he now looks to end his suffering by
dishing out some cold Revenge Chef
slowik's latest menu is simply him
punishing those that have brought him
into this life and embody everything
he's grown to hate about the avant-garde
food world including Petty food critics
narcissistic businessmen and pretentious
Foodies this growing disdain perfectly
explains Chef slowex generally cold
presence in fact his existence has
become so so bad that he would rather
die than have to cook another meal ever
again I've been fooled in trying to
satisfy people who can never be
satisfied
Chef slowik gradually reveals why he is
ready to end it all and gets some cold
revenge on his guests however it's more
difficult to figure out why his staff is
so willing to follow him into the abyss
most of them are young and could have
some promising cooking careers ahead of
them thanks to the impeccable dishes
they serve so why are they willing to go
down in flames and never even think
about fighting back sadly the answer is
that there's no place they'd rather be
it would be easy to say that Chef slowik
simply brainwashes the cooks to follow
his order because of how in sync they
are with him at every turn truthfully
everyone's more than willing to be there
just so they can work for Chef slowik
slowik's staff represents the Allure of
Desperately wanting to make it in a
tough industry and the willingness to do
just about anything to attain accolades
and respect they might know that this
will be the last meal they cook but if
they're working on Chef slowex
Masterpiece then it's an opportunity
they can't pass up it's basically the
same reason that people don't quit after
Gordon Ramsay screams and yells at them
during service their staying mentality
he embodies their views of their art
being more valued alongside Chef slowik
even in death
throughout the film there's a silver
door in the restaurant that catches the
attention of Anya Taylor Joy's Margo
which adds another mystery to the whole
ordeal once Margot was able to go into
Chef slowik's house while running an
errand for him she discovers what's
behind an identical door in his house
what she finds could be easily
considered Chef slow explaining and
motivation room since there were
newspaper clippings on the walls of some
of his reviews and photos that embody
his rise to prominence however Margo
makes a more important discovery that
inspires her fight for survival in his
secret room she sees a photo of Chef
sawick working as a chef at a local
Burger Joint he's smiling and it looks
as though he truly has a passion for
cooking it might look unimportant to
most but Margo sees it as a symbol of
Chef slowik's love for food and a
reminder of the simpler life he had
before becoming a world famous culinary
or tour as well as giving Margo the
opportunity to survive Chef slowik's
final meal it delves deep into the
chef's psyche guess what
yes chef
Chef slowik tells Margot that his guests
are being punished for destroying his
love of food he reveals that they also
embody a world of cooking that's devoid
of any real passion but he views her as
different unlike the other guests he
respects her and believes that she is
much more real than anyone else sitting
in the dining room despite this respect
Chef slowik doesn't plan on letting
Margo go so she's forced to figure out a
way to leave on her own inspired by the
photo of Chef slowik cooking burgers in
his youth Margot challenges him to make
her a simple cheeseburger and fries in
this moment there's a legitimate power
shift and Margot even does Chef slowik's
signature hand clap to get everyone's
attention with confidence she looks
totally in control as she served a
mouth-watering burger with fries by
touching on the chef's long buried
desire to make simple food with love
Margot finds a way to escape from his
revenge menu
margot's discovery of Chef slowik's past
as a Burger Chef is a major turning
point in the film and heavily inspires
her to order a cheeseburger in order to
possibly save herself her request is
granted and Chef slowik makes one hell
of a plate of cheeseburger and fries
that makes you want to rip it off the
screen and eat it yourself but there's
more to this cheeseburger than meets the
eye I'll make you feel as if you're
eating the first cheeseburger you ever
ate not only does this cheeseburger
connect to a former part of Chef
slowik's Life as a chef who genuinely
love to cook but it symbolizes a part of
cooking that's lost on most of the
people in the room it represents that
brand of easy cooking that's Timeless
and never needs to be flashy in order to
establish a connection with people it's
innocent and has real flavor to it not
because of special spices but because
the love and touch of the person cooking
it is present in every bite when I eat
your food
it tastes like it was made with no love
Chef slowik doesn't even prepare a fancy
cheeseburger and fries instead it's just
a nice simple Burger sitting on top of a
paper plate that easily puts a smile on
a person's face it certainly puts a
smile on Chef slowex face and reignites
his radiating love of food that had been
gone for so long now that
there's a cheeseburger
after getting Chef slowik to fill her
request for a cheeseburger there's a
tense moment in which everyone wonders
if he'll actually let Margot go even in
her request to have the rest of the meal
to go viewers can't help but question if
her rules will actually work but
surprisingly it does Chef slowik wraps
up all her food in a paper bag gives her
a party favor back and tells his staff
to let her walk out the door and leave
but why does he have a change of heart
when it comes to Margot this menu this
guest list this entire evening has been
painstakingly planned and you are not a
part of that plan throughout the menu
Chef slower constantly tells Margo that
she's different from the other guests
because she seems more genuine and real
and isn't meant to be there in the first
place by ordering a cheeseburger Margo
proves that she's not like anyone else
in the room as she can appreciate a
simple home-cooked meal Chef slowik
likely lets her go because she doesn't
deserve to die with the rest of the room
or because he respects how clever she is
when she makes that to-go request either
way Margot uses Chef slowik's original
love of food to make a last-ditch f to
survive and it totally works
once Margot was allowed to leave
everyone wonders if Chef slowik will
have a change of heart and in the
Bloodshed that's consumed the night
after all Chef slowik has been reminded
of his love of food and cooked a meal
that brings some genuine warmth to the
character for the first time in the film
however once Margot leaves he reverts
back to his old form as the final course
is ready to be served so why doesn't
Margo's cheeseburger request change
anything for chef slowik chef slowik
doesn't have a real change of heart at
any point and he's still committed to
his final menu just because Marco showed
that she isn't like the others in the
room doesn't mean that it changes
anything for any of the other diners or
Chef slowik he always felt that Margo
was different and once she's out of the
line of fire there's nothing stopping
him from completing his Masterpiece
frankly even the other guests seem to
accept their fate as no one tries to
stop Chef slowik in the final moments in
fact Judith lights and even waves for
Margot to leave showing that the
remaining guests are already resigned to
their fate although Margot was able to
escape the other guests are basically
trapped for the final course Chef slowik
suggests that the diners could fight
back and he even allows the men to run
and hide on the island during the men's
Folly course but in all seriousness
could anyone else actually Escape if
they tried to our male diners we now
offer you the chance to escape the
answer is likely no the Hawthorne staff
are plenty fit to fight off any physical
advances made by their guests and no one
is able to effectively hide during their
terrifying rendition of hide and seek
even if other diners tried to play on
Chef slowex Humanity in the way that
Margot did he would probably see their
attempts as insincere and keep them
captive anyway throughout the film the
guests are told There's No Escape for
them and that seems like the case right
up to The Bitter End after all the many
Horrors seen throughout the night
everyone's left wondering what Chef
slowik has up his sleeve for the final
course especially as it's likely going
to be the last meal anyone has like any
classic or tour Chef he can't do
something simple and goes for an
avant-garde take on s'mores as for why
he chooses this particular dish Chef
slowik talks about s'mores being the
staple of any innocent childhood curling
up around the fire with family and
friends roasting marshmallows this final
course seemingly represents the
Innocence that was lost by Chef slowik
himself throughout his career instead of
roasting marshmallows the plan is to
roast everyone inside Hawthorne it's a
visually stunning dish prepared in a
typically theatrical fashion everything
and every one Going Up in Flames is a
horrifying sight to behold especially as
all of the guests are covered in
marshmallows it's a fiery final course
with some solid symbolism and horrifying
conclusions
with Chef slowik's menu finally coming
together and his final course in action
there's only one way for things to end
and that in Flames just after saying his
goodbyes and giving his final words to
the guests Chef slowik lights the room
Ablaze and puts an end to this night of
Horus meanwhile Margo's Escape is not
quite going to plan since the boat
breaks down on the water from her point
of view we see the final results of Chef
slowik's menu and what's left of
Hawthorne as Margot looks back at
Hawthorne she sees Flames bursting out
of Windows and the entire building
starting to burn down the restaurant and
possibly the entire Island will simply
turn to Ash before anyone can save it
Chef slowik's Vision has been fully
realized the final course also presents
the perfect backdrop for Margot to
Simply keep eating her cheeseburger in
peace knowing that she survived while a
sequel to the menu hasn't been announced
fans are wondering whether Chef slowik
might return to torment a new set of
guests in the future however the movie
ends pretty definitively with the
completion of the chef's menu literally
going up in smoke as Chef slowik is last
seen inside the restaurant with the
guest and his staff it seems unlikely
that he has any plans to escape the
fiery mess of his own making you
represent the ruin of my art
in my life at the end of the menu
Hawthorne is burned to the ground Margo
was the sole survivor Chef slowik's
Legacy is destroyed by his own
Masterpiece with no real successor
mentioned or hinted at as a result it
seems likely that the menu is a superb
one-off Horror Story full of decadent
food sharp comedy and disturbing moments
if you or anyone you know is having
suicidal thoughts please dial or text
988 to speak with the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline you can also seek
help by visiting 988 lifeline.org